Di criptovalute su pensieri in codice non abbiamo ancora mai parlato, o almeno non abbiamo
dedicato un episodio specifico all'argomento.
Si tratta però di una delle tecnologie più interessanti e importanti degli ultimi anni.
Il mondo degli asset digitali, infatti, in tutte le sue molteplici forme, sta subendo
un processo di espansione e diffusione pari a pochi altri.
Le tecnologie che hanno visto un'esplosione di simili dimensioni si contano letteralmente
sulle dita di una mano.
E siccome poco più di un mese fa è stato annunciato l'ennesimo importante passo avanti,
ho voluto cogliere l'occasione per produrre un episodio nel quale fare un'interessantissima
introduzione.
Tra poco, dunque, parleremo di criptovalute e asset digitali e lo faremo con un ospite
d'eccezione che su questi argomenti ha fondato la propria carriera e perfino una società
di ricerca e analisi.
Sigla.
Benvenuti su Pensieri in codice, il podcast dove si ragiona da informatici, con Valerio Galano.
Penso di averlo già detto più di una volta, Pensieri in Codice è sì un podcast con il
quale mi piace, nel mio piccolo, provare a fare un po' di divulgazione informatica, ma
d'altro canto è anche un progetto che utilizzo io stesso per imparare ogni giorno cose nuove.
La maggior parte delle volte ciò si concretizza nello studiare quante più fonti possibili
e nel ricombinare tutte le informazioni così acquisite in modo semplice e lineare dando
vita agli script degli episodi, ma a volte capita che certi argomenti, seppur mi appaiano
interessanti, siano oggettivamente troppo lontani dal mio ambito di competenza per poterne
approfondire da solo gli aspetti più intriganti. Ci sono settori dell'informatica che richiedono
anni di studio e sarebbe davvero presuntuoso da parte mia pensare di poterli comprendere
o addirittura essere in grado di spiegarli con sole 10 o 20 ore di studio. Ed è così
che nascono gli episodi di Pensieri in Codice come quello di oggi, in cui chiedo l'aiuto
di un esperto che gentilmente si presta a condividere un po' della propria conoscenza
con noi e a raccontarci cose interessanti. Dunque, oggi abbiamo qui con noi Andrea Venturelli,
founder di Decrypto e ricercatore in campo di Digital Asset. Ciao Andrea e benvenuto!
Ciao Valerio, grazie, un piacere essere qua.
Grazie a te, è un piacere mio. Innanzitutto, Andrea, ci vuoi spiegare di cosa si occupa
DeCrypto e, nello specifico, di cosa ti occupi tu in DeCrypto?
Allora, Valerio, The Crypto è la mia società che si occupa di ricerca e analisi in campo
Bitcoin e Digital Asset, che cosa significa in termini semplici, che cosa facciamo in
termini semplici?
Siamo una piccola azienda, ci dedichiamo ad un target molto specifico e piccolo di clienti
che sono persone che tendenzialmente...
già hanno degli investimenti o sono interessati al mondo degli investimenti, non sono ragazzini,
ma parliamo di persone che hanno almeno 35-40 anni e che vogliono gestire al meglio il loro
patrimonio.
Quindi noi facciamo innanzitutto delle analisi dei portafogli per capire lo stato del portafoglio
della persona, quindi andiamo a capire se ci sono dei problemi lato sicurezza, se ci
sono dei problemi lato dell'asset allocation o metriche finanziarie che potrebbero essere
migliorate e poi eroghiamo dei percorsi di formazione esclusivamente per queste persone.
Dico che abbiamo un po' il piede in due scarpe solitamente perché...
Noi lavoriamo tanto con degli investitori privati e quindi abbiamo il polso, riusciamo
a capire esattamente che cosa le persone vogliono e come dovrebbero investire le persone nel
mondo dei digital asset, ma dall'altra parte lavoriamo anche con dei fondi di investimento.
I fondi di investimento sono, diciamo, quelle entità che...
riescono a guadagnare anche grazie alle perdite degli investitori privati, per cui noi avendo
un po' il piede in due scarpe diciamo che riusciamo a bilanciare e fare una formazione
che tendenzialmente non si trova su YouTube, non si trova gratuitamente e che è una formazione
di alta qualità per riuscire ad investire e creare un portafoglio che riesca ad avere
delle buone performance, che possa soprattutto rispettare i tuoi obiettivi di vita, i tuoi
obiettivi finanziari nel lungo termine.
Bene, quindi tu e la tua azienda siete chiaramente esperti nel mondo delle criptovalute.
In generale, però, anche senza essere necessariamente esperti o investitori, un po' tutti ormai
abbiamo sentito almeno parlare di Bitcoin, Ethereum, Solana, ultimamente Trump o Melania.
Allora io ti chiedo, in effetti, se volessimo parlare in termini teorici o accademici, qual
è la vera e propria definizione di criptovaluta?
Allora, utilizzare la parola criptovaluta, a mio modo di vedere e a nostro modo di vedere
come società di ricerca e analisi, è abbastanza fuorviante, perché in realtà secondo me
è molto più semplice dividere il mercato in due grandi categorie.
Da una parte abbiamo la criptovaluta, l'unica criptovaluta che...
effettivamente esiste oggi e che viene utilizzata oggi, che si chiama bitcoin, che penso che
quasi tutti oramai hanno sentito.
E poi dall'altra parte invece abbiamo delle aziende, delle aziende, dei progetti.
Ecco, queste aziende e progetti non creano delle criptovalute, non mirano ad essere delle
valute, non mirano ad essere dei mezzi di pagamento.
Solana, per esempio, per citarne una, non mira ad essere un mezzo di pagamento né tanto
meno Ethereum, né tanto meno Trump o Melania, come hai citato tu, ecco, ma sono dei progetti,
in alcuni casi sono delle aziende, in alcuni casi sono dei progetti, in alcuni casi sono
delle truffe vere e proprie.
Ecco, quindi questo mondo è un mondo che purtroppo è ancora, purtroppo per fortuna,
è un mondo che è ancora regolamentato per metà, quindi significa che ci sono tantissime
truffe e che l'aspetto numero uno da tenere a mente, come prima cosa per chi vuole investire
in questo settore, è la sicurezza.
È meglio fare meno che fare troppo in questo settore, perché altrimenti si rischia di
sbagliare, si rischiano di perdere soldi o si rischia di incappare in truffe, e per
truffe non intendo la truffa in stile Vannamarki che ti vende il sale o cose di questo tipo,
ma intendo truffe molto più sofisticate in cui cascano anche esperti o operatori del
settore.
Per cui, tornando alla tua domanda Valerio, la distinzione che secondo me e secondo noi
come società di ricerca facciamo?
è proprio quella di dividere in due grandi categorie, da una parte abbiamo Bitcoin, che
è la criptovaluta, nata per essere un mezzo di pagamento alternativo alle banche senza
intermediari e soprattutto per poter scambiare del valore in ogni parte del mondo senza dover
chiedere il permesso a nessuno.
Questa è la grande forza di Bitcoin ed è.
è la vera missione iniziale di bitcoin. Dopodiché per chi studia bitcoin è innegabile che
bitcoin è...
come dire, strizza l'occhio all'oro per come è stato costruito, anche in alcuni termini
che magari poi affronteremo oggi insieme.
Quando parliamo dei miner, quindi dei minatori, si parla degli estrattori.
di nuovi bitcoin, un po' come quelli che estraggono l'oro, i minatori di oro, quindi
ci sono diverse somiglianze nel modo in cui è stato costruito bitcoin per assomigliare
all'oro.
Questo è il motivo per cui bitcoin non solo è mezzo di pagamento, ma per esempio ad alcune
persone, compresa anche la nuova amministrazione americana, è definito proprio oro digitale
bitcoin.
Dall'altra parte invece non abbiamo né tanto meno delle monete né tanto meno un oro digitale,
dall'altra parte noi abbiamo quelli che potremmo definire più con il nome di token o con il
nome di digital asset o con il nome di altcoin, ecco la definizione probabilmente è poco
importante se si chiamano altcoin, digital asset o token.
A noi quello che ci serve capire però è che questi token sono prima di tutto questi
strumenti, degli strumenti che servono per raccogliere il capitale, è un po' come se
fossero degli strumenti di crowdfunding per intenderci, cioè noi vogliamo creare una
nuova società, dobbiamo raccogliere del denaro come se fossimo una normale startup e anziché
andare
a chiedere, per esempio, soldi agli investitori, a andare a chiedere debiti in banca, andare
a compilare dei bandi, ci sono diverse forme di finanziamento oggi, fra cui c'è il finanziamento
attraverso i token. Quindi noi innanzitutto dobbiamo capire questa grandissima differenza.
Purtroppo questa differenza non è...
spiegata in termini semplici non è la luce del sole se noi andiamo su
qualsiasi piattaforma di investimento
perché in una piattaforma di investimento noi troviamo bitcoin e poi troviamo tutto
il resto
come se fosse più o meno tutto uguale
infatti si parla anche del bitcoin di Trump come se Trump avesse creato il suo
bitcoin
ed è chiaramente disinformazione perché
Trump non ha creato il suo bitcoin, Trump ha creato semplicemente un token, in particolar
modo una meme coin, quindi poi magari entriamo anche nella definizione poi più avanti, Valerio,
insieme di i vari strumenti che ci sono in questo mondo, però iniziando nel modo più
semplice in assoluto dividiamo in due grandi categorie.
la criptovaluta bitcoin e il resto invece che sono token emessi da aziende.
Ok, chiaro. Quindi, focalizzandoci sul Bitcoin in quanto criptovaluta, possiamo dire che
l'esistenza di questo strumento è alla base di quello che potremmo definire un sistema
monetario totalmente virtuale. E allora, quello che ti chiedo è, da un punto di vista tecnico,
almeno a grandi linee, ci puoi spiegare come fa a funzionare una cosa del genere? In pratica,
come fa a funzionare Bitcoin?
Allora, questa è una domanda per quanto semplice.
essere estremamente complessa. Partiamo proprio dalle basi poi cerchiamo di scendere mano a mano
in profondità. Allora innanzitutto...
Quando si parla di bitcoin si parla, abbiamo capito, dell'unica vera criptovaluta che le
persone utilizzano e che
come dire, è molto simile all'oro e per qualche...
Per alcune persone, o per esempio il governo americano oggi definito oro digitale, quello
che noi innanzitutto dobbiamo capire è che Bitcoin nasce nel 2009, per la precisione
il 3 gennaio del 2009.
quando nasce? Nasce nel momento in cui viene creato il primo blocco della blockchain. Blockchain
probabilmente è un termine che penso che ormai quasi tutti hanno sentito almeno una
volta. Magari lo hanno capito, magari lo hanno capito invece un po' meno. Blockchain è
semplicemente la tecnologia sottostante a bitcoin. Che cos'è? Significa che
La blockchain di bitcoin è formata da un blocco uno dopo l'altro, sequenziali, significa
che all'interno del blocco ci sono tutte le transazioni che noi possiamo mandare, proprio
come dobbiamo vederlo come se fosse una sorta di registro pubblico, trasparente, che tutti
possono guardare, ma in forma pseudonima, vuol dire che dentro questi blocchi ci sono
tutte le transazioni, sia mie che tue che di tutte le altre persone, però sono in forma
pseudonima, vuol dire che non c'è il nostro nome, il nostro cognome, il nostro codice
fiscale o il numero della carta d'identità, ma ci sono delle lettere, dei numeri, insomma
delle stringhe alfanumeriche, ecco questo è il modo in cui bitcoin non è anonimo,
bitcoin è pseudonimo.
Им.
all'interno di questi blocchi ci sono tutte le transazioni che sono avvenute.
Questi blocchi sono sequenziali, vuol dire che per andare al blocco il blocco 2
è agganciato al blocco 1, il blocco 3 è agganciato al blocco 2 e così via e che
Il vero valore di Bitcoin è dato dal fatto che questi blocchi non possono essere riavvolti,
cioè noi non possiamo riavvolgere la storia.
Questi blocchi sono formati un blocco ogni 10 minuti circa.
Questo vuol dire che dal 2009 ad oggi sono stati creati migliaia e migliaia di blocchi.
Questi blocchi, al loro interno, contengono tutte le transazioni.
Beep.
Questa blockchain, quindi questo registro pubblico distribuito, trasparente, con tutti
i nostri nomi però in forma alfanumerica, quindi in forma pseudonima, è distribuito
su migliaia di nodi in giro per il mondo.
Questo è il motivo per cui viene definito decentralizzato, perché tutti noi, con un
computer...
anche un computer molto vecchio Valerio, perché io ti dico che ho un nodo di Bitcoin che gira
su un computer Mac vecchio su cui ci ho installato Linux che è del 2010-2011 con un hard disk
da 1TB, un hard disk meccanico da 1TB, ecco quindi anche un computer vecchio di 15 anni
può tenere la blockchain di Bitcoin.
distribuire e al tempo stesso rendere decentralizzato e inattaccabile
tutto il sistema di bitcoin.
Dopodiché
ci sono altre entità, cioè non ci sono solamente i nodi, che sono questi
computer in giro per il mondo
che ogni dieci minuti si aggiornano per scrivere un nuovo blocco della blockchain.
In questo modo se qualcuno falsifica qualcosa si vede subito
perché ci sono migliaia di nodi che invece
possono
possono dire se qualcuno sta falsificando qualche transazione quindi è
di gran lunga uno dei sistemi più sicuri che noi abbiamo, molto più sicuro e molto più
trasparente dell'attuale sistema bancario.
All'interno del network, della grande macchina di Bitcoin, abbiamo altre
due principali entità. La prima entità, di cui ho anche parlato prima, sono i miner, per cui i minatori.
Inizialmente erano dei semplici computer come dei laptop o dei computer...
normali, casalinghi, nel corso del tempo questi computer, l'industria del mining di bitcoin
si è ingrandita sempre di più e la competizione ha fatto sì che non si potesse più fare
mining con un semplice computer.
da tavolo o computer casalingo, ma che bisognasse
comprare
degli hardware appositi per poter fare questo lavoro.
Ecco, il mining oggi è un'industria vera e propria, è un'industria come l'industria
del mining dell'oro e le società che fanno mining sono società che sono persino quotate
in borsa.
Questa è la seconda entità che lavora nel network di bitcoin per far sì di includere
all'interno dei blocchi della blockchain di cui abbiamo parlato prima tutte le transazioni
che vengono effettuate ogni dieci minuti.
il miner che riesce a
vincere una sorta di, chiamiamola, gara, una sorta di competizione che avviene ogni dieci minuti,
si becca una ricompensa.
Questa ricompensa non è altro che l'inflazione di bitcoin e senza andare in troppi tecnicismi
passiamo a quella che invece è la terza entità che siamo noi, quindi sono tutti gli utenti
che possono utilizzare bitcoin.
Bitcoin viene utilizzato
Inizialmente era utilizzato per scambiare denaro in forma peer-to-peer, quindi in forma
decentralizzata senza nessun intermediario, oggi Bitcoin ha un ruolo invece che è cambiato
nel corso del tempo, la narrativa di Bitcoin è cambiata nel corso del tempo e oggi per
lo più le persone o speculano sul rialzo o ribasso di Bitcoin oppure semplicemente
fanno un po' quello che le persone fanno anche con l'oro, quindi nel corso del tempo
lo accumulano per proteggere il loro potere di acquisto.
Quindi queste sono le tre principali entità da cui è formato Bitcoin, abbiamo i nodi,
abbiamo i miners e abbiamo gli utenti.
E questo è a grandi linee, Valerio, il modo in cui Bitcoin funziona oggi.
much.
chiarissimo. Quindi, dopo oltre 20 anni dalla nascita di Bitcoin, il panorama delle criptovalute
ne conta ormai decine di migliaia, ma tu oggi ci hai fatto scoprire che non tutte sono realmente
definibili criptovalute, anzi, che la maggior parte sono invece dei token. Ci chiarisci
questo punto.
Sì, come dicevamo poco fa, noi da una parte abbiamo Bitcoin, dall'altra parte abbiamo
delle aziende.
Il funzionamento di Bitcoin più o meno poi è il funzionamento anche di altri progetti
come per esempio sono Ethereum, come per esempio sono Solana, Cardano, Ripple, cioè il funzionamento
di base a grandi linee senza entrare in dettagli tecnici è più o meno tutto uguale.
Quello che cambia è che Bitcoin è nato come moneta e oggi viene definito oro digital o
uno strumento speculativo, dall'altra parte invece abbiamo delle aziende che sviluppano
degli applicativi di business.
Queste aziende...
creano delle criptovalute come tu hai giustamente detto Valerio anche se
sono più definibili quasi dei token o degli asset digitali, vengono chiamati oggi. Qual è
la differenza fra per esempio Ethereum e il token di Trump? La differenza è che il token
di Trump è semplicemente un token.
key.
gravita e viaggia e viene scambiato sulla blockchain, in questo caso di Solana.
Possono essere scambiati sulla blockchain di Solana, possono essere scambiati sulla
blockchain di Ethereum, di SUI, di Aptos, di Cardano, eccetera.
Quindi vediamo proprio queste blockchain come se fossero delle infrastrutture.
Sopra queste infrastrutture vengono creati, per esempio, dei token.
Alcuni token sono completamente stupidi e privi di alcun senso, come per esempio il
token di Trump, non aveva alcun senso, è solo un quello speculativo, mentre ci sono
degli altri progetti che...
esempio molto semplice da capire, sono i token che rappresentano dei beni reali,
quindi per esempio dei token che rappresentano la tokenizzazione di
oggetti reali, come per esempio possono essere degli immobili, degli oggetti di
lusso, possono essere delle opere d'arte, possono essere anche degli strumenti
finanziari, per cui i titoli di stato, per esempio americani, alcuni di essi possono
essere comprati sulla blockchain perché tokenizzati. Quindi vediamo proprio
ethereum come solana, come altri progetti che magari le persone sentono e
ascoltano, non come delle criptovalute ma come delle infrastrutture che servono ai
fini di business e sopra queste infrastrutture possono viaggiare diversi
token
che possono essere dall'aspetto più speculativo e stupido, che tendenzialmente è quello che
fanno vedere i giornali, quello di cui parlano un po' tutti, ma in realtà sotto alla superficie
se scaviamo un pochino, ecco questo poi dopo è il nostro lavoro in decripto, di eliminare
tutto il rumore, tutte le porcherie, tutte le schifezze di cui spesso si parla, per invece
tenere quello che è realmente...
quelli che sono i segnali, cioè togli il rumore e teniamo i segnali, teniamo le cose importanti, quelle da capire.
di quelle su cui, per esempio, un investitore si vuole esporre, si vuole...
iniziare a
e per esempio investire in
in questo settore.
Se ho capito bene, Decrypto si occupa di fare analisi e consulenza nel campo dei digital
assets, quindi in pratica erogate consulenza a riguardo alla cosiddetta finanza decentralizzata.
Ci vuoi spiegare allora cosa si intende in effetti per finanza decentralizzata e quali
sono le differenze pratiche rispetto a quella classica?
Allora, questa è un'ottima domanda, sì, noi ci occupiamo di consulenza tecnologica
e non finanziaria, nel senso che i consulenti finanziari sono nostri clienti e proprio perché
devono imparare questo nuovo, letteralmente un nuovo mondo, un nuovo modo anche di operare,
di analizzare, di capire una nuova generazione di asset che prima non esisteva.
Venendo alla tua domanda in merito alla finanza decentralizzata, la finanza, anche qui, chiamarla
finanza decentralizzata, può sembrare
può essere forviante perché in realtà la finanza così definita decentralizzata di
decentralizzato, se devo essere proprio onesto con te Valerio, ha gran poco. La finanza decentralizzata
non sono altro che delle aziende o delle istituzioni che
operano sulla blockchain. Che cos'ha di diverso allora se non è decentralizzata questa nuova
finanza rispetto alla finanza tradizionale, la finanza che tutti un po' odiamo, la finanza
che è difficile, la finanza che fa gli sbagli e quindi socializza le perdite ma invece privatizza
i guadagni. Qual è la differenza fra la finanza, quella di Wall Street, quella che noi vediamo
molto lontana dalle nostre vite e invece la finanza decentralizzata? Beh, la differenza
principale è che la finanza decentralizzata è innanzitutto aperta, è open, è aperta a chiunque.
Perché? Perché non ti serve registrarti da nessuna parte, non devi dare il tuo ID, non devi dare la
tua carta d'identità, non devi dare la tua prova di residenza, le bollette, il selfie. Noi tutti
sappiamo le verifiche dell'identità che le banche online, i servizi online oggi ci chiedono. La
finanza decentralizzata è aperta a tutti, questo non significa che quindi ci sono solamente criminali
sulla finanza decentralizzata come spesso poi passa nei media mainstream. La finanza
decentralizzata è aperta a tutti, ci sono criminali ma ci sono anche tante persone che invece non
potrebbero...
accedere ai servizi finanziari tradizionali semplicemente perché hanno la sfortuna di essere nati in posti poveri, essere unbanked, quindi
non essere
attraenti per le banche e quindi le banche non gli aprono i conti correnti a queste persone. Queste persone grazie
per esempio la finanza decentralizzata, possono invece accedere a un sistema finanziario globale
interconnesso e avere le stesse opportunità che abbiamo noi nei paesi invece sviluppati
da un punto di vista finanziario, quindi la prima grande differenza è che la finanza
decentralizzata rispetto alla finanza tradizionale è aperta a tutti quanti.
La seconda grande differenza è che
interoperabile. Cosa significa interoperabile? Significa che se io devo mandare i soldi da
un wallet ad un altro, da un portafoglio ad un altro, li devo mandare durante il weekend,
durante la notte o a Natale o dall'altra parte del mondo, beh, è tutto molto più
interconnesso, è tutto molto più rapido, è tutto senza frizioni.
E qui vengo al terzo punto importante di cui ho già accennato, che è il fatto di essere
permissionless.
Cosa significa questa parola inglese?
Significa che non hai bisogno del permesso di nessuno per poter accedere a questa finanza.
Vuol dire che non hai bisogno di verifiche dell'identità, vuol dire che puoi scambiare
soldi dall'Italia alla Cina al Centro America, cosa che invece col sistema finanziario attuale
non possiamo.
O meglio, se possiamo è comunque molto costoso e soprattutto è molto lento il nostro sistema
finanziario, quello che noi spesso vediamo quando paghiamo il caffè, il pane o la spesa
con la carta.
vediamo che è immediato. La realtà è che dietro invece gli istituti finanziari per
regolare i conti fra le carte di credito, fra i bonifici, fra i vari diversi istituti
bancari possono impiegarci settimane se non mesi. Quando l'esercente accetta i pagamenti
virtuali i pagamenti non vengono automaticamente accreditati sul tuo conto ma hanno bisogno
del tempo per essere accreditati perché ci devono essere tutte le verifiche del caso.
Ecco nel mondo della finanza invece decentralizzata è tutto molto più semplice, è tutto quindi
open, aperto.
cross border, quindi non ha bisogno di ponti, non ha bisogno di...
Non ci sono confini.
e non ha bisogno del permesso di nessuno, quindi tutti quanti possono accedere, possono
creare infiniti portafogli, che significa l'equivalente di dire creare infiniti account
bancari, avere infiniti IBAN costantemente e preservare la propria privacy, ma al tempo
stesso garantisce una trasparenza che il mondo finanziario tradizionale non garantisce, perché
tutto quello che
tutti
tutti i documenti, tutte le frizioni che il sistema tradizionale finanziario ha oggi non
garantiscono
non garantiscono il fatto che questo sistema tradizionale finanziario sia pulito, che sia
a prova di criminale, anzi tutt'altro, noi sappiamo che i criminali preferiscono molto
di più i dollari che le criptovalute, per esempio, e quindi il sistema finanziario decentralizzato,
così definito, mette insieme una serie di cose, fra cui la privacy, ma al tempo stesso
la trasparenza e al tempo stesso la possibilità di utilizzare un sistema che ovunque tu ti
trovi nel mondo puoi accedere ai migliori servizi finanziari a un costo bassissimo senza
dover per forza perdere tutta la tua privacy, come invece avviene con il mondo finanziario
tradizionale.
Chiarissimo. Per concludere, di recente c'è stato un avvenimento piuttosto importante
nel mondo dell'ecritto, lo dicevo nell'introduzione. Cioè, la Stablecoin USDT è entrata a far
parte del cosiddetto Lightning Network. Allora ti chiedo innanzitutto cosa vuol dire questa
affermazione e poi perché è un avvenimento così importante.
Allora, certamente facciamo un passo indietro. Che cos'è USDT e che cos'è Lightning Network? Per
capire che cos'è USDT dobbiamo sapere che cos'è una stablecoin. Quindi una stablecoin non è altro
che, come dicevamo prima, è un token che viaggia sopra una blockchain, che rappresenta un bene
reale, qualcosa di reale, qualcosa che c'è nel mondo fisico. In questo caso le stablecoin
rappresentano dei dollari. Quindi un
dollaro tokenizzato
è l'equivalente di un dollaro nella vita reale.
Questo è un business in realtà grandissimo, anzi
a dire la verità è il business più grande del mondo cripto, ossia quello di
prendere dei dollari reali
investirli in titoli di Stato americani che rendono circa un 4-5% oggi e dare a noi utenti
dei dollari tokenizzati che possiamo utilizzare, per esempio, nella finanza decentralizzata.
Questo che può sembrare un business in realtà molto complesso è, a dire la verità, molto
semplice e soprattutto è molto remunerativo, cioè USDT, che è un dollaro tokenizzato
sulle blockchain, a cui dietro a garanzia ci sono dei dollari reali.
è stato creato da un'azienda di italiani che si chiama Tether, che oggi è l'azienda
più grande del mondo cripto. Per dare giusto due metriche, per capire la grandezza di quest'azienda
che magari non avete sentito, Tether, innanzitutto, poche settimane fa si è comprata un pezzo
della Juventus, sta facendo investimenti di...
come di venture capital in diversi rami, non solamente sulla blockchain ma anche per esempio
in intelligenza artificiale, per esempio in applicazioni lato privacy, che sono sicuro
che qui Valerio tratterai o hai già trattato.
Quello che è incredibile di USTT è che è un'azienda che è riuscita a fatturare nel
2024, anzi è riuscita ad avere come utili, non come fatturato, ma come utili più di
10 miliardi di dollari con 60 dipendenti.
quindi è l'azienda al mondo che per numero di dipendenti ha più utili in
assoluto. Quindi stiamo parlando di un'azienda che è enorme.
Ad oggi l'amministratore delegato di Tether
è
discussione con la Casa Bianca per scrivere un regolamento per quanto
riguarda le stablecoin, mentre in Europa USDT e Tether non sono neanche
regolamentati perché le nuove regole europee vietano di utilizzare le riserve
di Tether nel modo in cui sono utilizzate oggi, però senza entrare in
dettagli troppo tecnici. Capiamo una volta che sappiamo ora che cos'è una
stablecoin e sappiamo che cos'è USDT e quanto è importante l'azienda Tether nel
mondo cripto, che è l'azienda che ha creato USDT, capiamo che cos'è Lightning
Network, perché Lightning Network è come se fosse una sorta di livello secondario
che viaggia sopra Bitcoin. Prima abbiamo detto che per creare un blocco della
blockchain di Bitcoin ci vogliono i miner, ci vogliono i nodi e soprattutto
bisogna aspettare 10 minuti per essere incluso nel blocco successivo, la nostra
transazione deve essere inclusa nel blocco successivo.
Ecco Lightning Network, vediamolo come una sorta di...
di autostrada secondaria in cui non ci sono semafori e che è molto più veloce e quindi
noi possiamo prendere quest'autostrada e scambiarci i nostri bitcoin in maniera istantanea ovunque
nel mondo senza bisogno di blockchain, blocchi, dieci minuti, miners eccetera, è tutto molto
più semplice e rapido. La grande notizia è che gli USDT, ossia dei dollari digitali
che vengono per lo più utilizzati in posti in cui non ci sono dollari, pensiamo ai posti
in cui c'è un'inflazione a doppia cifra o addirittura a tripla cifra ogni anno, noi
ci scandalizziamo perché c'è un'inflazione magari del 5, 6 o 10% come è avvenuto nel
2021-22, ecco ci sono posti in cui l'inflazione tocca il 100% ogni anno, quindi vuol dire
che il tuo guadagno, quello che tu guadagni con il tuo lavoro viene distrutto ogni anno
dall'inflazione. Ci sono questi posti come per esempio l'Argentina o come per esempio
il Venezuela in cui gli USDT è letteralmente una…
come dire, un
un modo per salvare i propri risparmi da quella che è l'inflazione. Per cui il USDT è per
lo più utilizzato in questi paesi, in paesi in cui c'è alta inflazione o paesi che semplicemente
vorrebbero detenere dollari e magari non possono perché le banche centrali di questi
paesi lo vietano. Ecco, in qualche modo anche l'Unione Europea sta correndo un po' ai ripari
cercando di vietare gli USDT, cercare di vietare questa fuori uscita di euro per comprare
dollari. Questo è il motivo per cui anche nelle ultime settimane la guard ha annunciato
che ci sarà l'euro digitale proprio per contrastare queste stable coin. La notizia è di
a mio modo di vedere è molto importante.
Valerio, perché va ad inserire i dollari sopra la blockchain più decentralizzata che
noi abbiamo, che è Bitcoin, su un network che è estremamente veloce, che è il Lightning
Network, per cui dal mio punto di vista è un'ottima notizia, ad oggi però ancora non
è possibile utilizzarlo e probabilmente ci vorranno degli anni prima che ci siano abbastanza
servizi, liquidità e, come dire, un ecosistema di applicazioni che ci permettano di avere
questi dollari sopra una blockchain decentralizzata come quella di Bitcoin da poter utilizzare
in tutto il mondo.
Perfetto, sei stato chiarissimo. Bene, Andrea, io ti ringrazio per essere stato con noi oggi
e soprattutto per averci aiutato a capire un bel po' di cose su questo mondo così interessante
e complesso.
ringrazio io Valerio per per l'invito e spero che sia stata una puntata utile per i tuoi ascoltatori
you
You
Sicuramente, non ho dubbi.
Bene, so che a questo punto sei già lì col ditino pronto per schippare al prossimo podcast,
ma aspetta un secondo perché Andrea mi ha lasciato un regalino per te, caro ascoltatore
di Pensieri in Codice. Se vuoi, infatti, puoi accedere al sito TheCrypto.space che ti lascio
in descrizione e utilizzare il codice sconto PENSIERI per ottenere un'analisi del tuo
portafoglio o una consulenza dedicata del valore di 99€ in maniera totalmente gratuita
e senza alcun impegno. Quindi, mi raccomando, approfittane! Detto questo, visto che sei
così gentile da aver ascoltato fin qui, ti voglio anche ricordare la storia del Value
for Value. Ti va? Pensieri in Codice è un progetto totalmente indipendente e libero
da pubblicità che porto avanti nel mio tempo libero e con le mie risorse personali. Ciò
vuol dire che per sopravvivere questo podcast ha bisogno del tuo supporto. Supporto che
puoi dare in tre modi, ti ricordi? Time, Talent o Treasure. Per Time intendo proprio il tuo
tempo, quello che potresti dedicare a condividere questo episodio o altri con chi pensi che
possa apprezzarlo. Il passaparola può funzionare tantissimo se lo fai con criterio. Pensaci,
se ognuno di voi condividesse questo episodio con un solo amico saremmo già il doppio.
Talent, invece, vuol dire che se possiedi una capacità o una competenza che possano
tornare utili per il podcast, potresti valutare di dedicarne una piccola parte a supportarmi.
Magari sai usare i social meglio di me, e ci vuole davvero poco perché io sono negato,
e puoi darmi una mano a mettere su un profilo su qualche piattaforma. Magari sai scrivere
e potresti aiutarmi con la stesura degli script, o magari hai qualche idea e me la vuoi proporre.
Non esitare perché io amo ricevere feedback utili e soprattutto collaborare con menti brillanti. Non
ti nego che al momento il mio obiettivo principale sarebbe quello di aumentare il numero di ascolti.
Se tu avessi una strategia da proporre, e magari addirittura da aiutarmi a portare avanti,
sarebbe davvero un'ottima cosa. E infine c'è Treasure, che è la cosa più semplice ma non
per questo meno apprezzata. Se ti va, e se pensi che il mio lavoro abbia un valore,
puoi scegliere di offrire un piccolo supporto economico. Non è obbligatorio, ovviamente,
ma per me sarebbe prezioso perché mi aiuterebbe a migliorare e portare avanti questo progetto con
serenità, diciamo così. Ed è questo il punto in cui ringrazio i due donatori più assidui di questo
podcast, Edoardo e Carlo, con la loro donazione mensile. E oggi a loro si unisce anche una
donazione spot da un anonimo. Grazie anche a te chiunque tu sia! A questo punto direi che davvero
non c'è altro per oggi e quindi noi ci sentiamo al prossimo episodio senza mai dimenticare che
un informatico risolve problemi a volte anche usando il computer.